mark is with us in boston hey mark
welcome to the ramsey show
thanks dave really appreciate how you
doing better than i deserve how can we
help
yeah so i'll uh a three little back
story here i'm currently
an undergraduate student full-time
enrolled
i have a full tuition scholarship i'm
also a resident advisor so i don't pay
room and board either
so i actually uh i net nothing at the
end of each semester
recently i just bought a car um i have
about ten thousand dollars in debt on
that
um there's a obviously a large push from
the left
pushing for uh student loan forgiveness
so i was wondering what your thoughts
would be on
pulling out student loans again and
transferring
paying off my car with those loans with
student loans
and possibly getting the chance to have
my car
loan that is now student loan forgiven
so i'm a taxpayer and i'm supposed to
pay off your car
with your student loan forgiveness don't
you think that's immoral
yeah a little bit but at the same time
it's um yeah
a little bit if the opportu if the
opportunity is there
um if the government's going to be
deciding to start handing out
money left and right why not take the
yeah so
um let me tell you the the there was a
book out several years ago called
millionaire next door by a man named tom
stanley who passed away it came out in
1992.
he did a book later called the
millionaire mind the millionaire next
door he studied millionaires the
millionaire mind he studied people that
had 10 million dollars decca
millionaires
and he looked for the character he
looked for the
correlating statistical points he was a
researcher
and people that had 10 million or more
and um he found demographic similarities
he found
uh career similarities and he found 38
statistical points of reference that
indicated that they were causal
that indicated that if you had a large
number of these you would have a high
indicator that you were heading towards
10 million or more and he listed them in
order
of the of you know the first one in
other words number one was the most
often occurring
38 was the least often occurring out of
the 38 points you understand what i'm
saying
and let me tell you what number one was
fanatical levels of integrity
you need to visit that and sit on that
because when you do not have fanatical
levels of integrity
you are missing the number one
correlating data point towards become
building wealth
versus how much can i scam the american
taxpayer out of
and get me a free car dude that's just
wrong
yeah it's just wrong
so no you should not do that a a a
really important mentor of mine posed an
important question back in my
20s and the question was this is
integrity something you can sort of have
you can mostly have
and that has just sat and sat inside me
for a long long time
because i lived some of my life thinking
yeah i mean mostly you know
and here's the thing dave
that bill's gonna come do for all of us
it's gonna come due for all of us
there's just no you you don't nobody
gets rich scamming the government the
taxpayers no
it's just you don't get wealthy that way
you know you don't get wealthy trying to
you know run a welfare scam you don't
get worse you don't run
you don't get wealthy running up uh
unemployment scam you don't get wealthy
scamming the
you know hiding your grandpa's assets so
you can get a government-funded medicaid
nursing home
which is illegal as crud it's called
welfare fraud but people do it every day
and so stealing is not a part of
integrity
why do you think decca millionaires what
what's the correlation there i don't
know a lot of deck of millionaires
uh the ones that i know anecdotally
align up with that
i mean everybody knows some you know any
group of people you can put them in a
room and there's there's idiots in
everybody
there's a jerk right there somebody that
doesn't have integrity so not all deca
millionaires do but there's a high
correlation to that
that when they interviewed their wife
when they interviewed their kids when
they interviewed their employees when
they interviewed their competitors
in the marketplace they said you know i
always agree with that guy but one thing
about it
if he says it's raining you better get
your umbrella you know
if he says if he says he's going to
lease hell on you you better get ready
because hell's coming
you know you better whatever he says
he's going to do he's going to do and so
uh
there's fanatical levels of integrity
and and i think it's because uh
most things in this world move on the
speed of trust i was gonna say i think
you could probably stumble and grit and
grind
and cut and cheat your way to three
million dollars but
to get ten you gotta have other people
walking alongside you gotta have
somebody else
lifting with you with you if they don't
trust you yeah and
trust is just a it's a mammoth thing uh
and yeah how you get trustworthy you're
unbelievably consistent and
you know the word integrity comes uh
from the same root word that we get the
word integer from
or integral okay and so the word integer
if you're a math nerd you know that
an integer is a whole number it has no
fraction
to it it's not 1.5 it's not 1.25 it's a
whole
it's two one three it's whole
and integrity is whole the whole person
and it's not like well i don't you know
i don't cheat on my
wife but i do cheat on my taxes you know
you know you're just a freaking cheat
it's just a matter of time
before it's revealed somewhere else it's
because it's that hole
and the the interesting thing about this
is the reason i'm wearing this young man
out is uh directly and indirectly and
people in our audience simultaneously
is that it's a choice you can grow up
being a cheat and just decide
i'm done yeah characters in the bible
jacob i'm done
jacob did it yeah he was known as the
deceiver
in the bible and then he became a man of
integrity you can just say
as of today i have integrity you can
just decide yeah you can't decide i'm
beautiful
you can't decide to grow hair i've tried
but you can just decide
i'm gonna have integrity that's gonna
tell the truth i'm gonna be a man i'm
gonna be a woman
that can be counted on and so i you know
i
you know once i got all that dialed into
my head like you know what i pay all my
taxes
every stinking dime i owe exactly
we don't have a side set of books like
we don't count the cash we count the
cash the cash is part of the profit it's
taxable income in america when you make
a cash profit on something you can hide
it
but i you but the but the law says and
my integrity says when i sign that tax
return
that it's real now i hate taxes and i
don't pay a dime more
than i have to and i spend money with
accountants trying to legally
use everything in the law to not pay it
right but once i know what's owed
i it's every if if i ever get audited
come on over be a hot knife through
butter because it's it's all right there
baby
i got nothing to hide and my guess is
your heart rate runs a little lower yeah
yeah
you sleep at night you sleep at night uh
you know well the whole thing you know i
don't have to remember what i don't have
to try to remember what i said because
whatever i said was what i said
right huh you know it's like we were
digging around in the
warehouse we closed up a warehouse this
week and they brought some of the old
files over
and i found a file in there i was going
through them this morning with my
assistant trying to figure out what to
throw away
and there's a file from 1999 with hate
mail
and um she she gets all my hate mail
anyway you know because her mail and
comes here and so she's like
this is the same thing they say right
now they hate you for exactly the same
reason that they did in 1999
i think we need to we need to read it on
the show oh i do need to do i'll bring
the file down
next week we'll do that yeah that's a
good idea but you know
i'm unbelievably consistent i'm even
hated for the same reason next week
we're gonna do an episode on my show
james
of just that 40 minutes of reading
letters it's going to be fantastic we're
all going to feel better about ourselves
well we used to do read mean tweets but
then oh that's all there are so
it would be all you have to do is open
it nice tweets that's right because
they're the rare ones there's three of
them that's right
three twitter is troll land but you know
the
the thing is that that
once as a young guy i figured out
reading these people and understanding
these people and it became a part of my
faith walk too
to tell the truth to be the truth to to
be consistent
it does get easier it's hard in the
moment
i mean he's got ten thousand dollars in
debt now yeah that might have might have
gone away if biden makes it go make
student loans go away
but um that's like fraud yeah
it it you know if you if you hide assets
so that you can get government money
yeah that's illegal
and my my challenge with the bailout
besides the fact that we don't have the
money is
dave i i didn't understand what i was
signing my wife and i signed for a lot
but at the end of the day i saw my name
on a piece of paper said i'll pay you
back yeah
you know what i mean that's right that's
wrestled in my that's just been in me
it's old school i told you i'll pay you
back i will you know
my challenge with it is it doesn't
bother me much it's just quit making the
stinking loans if you're going to
forgive them
it's intellectually dishonest you plug
the hole first right
yeah that's just why are you making them
if they're so that gun bad
stop making them and then we'll talk
about the rest of